i'm cooking and i'm seven years old
i live in valencia
do you know it's in spain it's a country
my mom and dad live with me
but they did not live here before
mum did but that did not
because
he's from germany which is over there
had to go there to germany
to meet dad
she said she wanted to study there
because people of germany gave her money
so she could study
well she says that
but don't take her seriously
i'm sure
she went there
to find them
because he's always lame
grandpa otto which is the dad of my dad
say that mum knew dad
because some people
broke a wall they had in germany
i'm sure they're broken because they
wanted more space
that makes sense
mom was going there in a hurry and she
could bump the wall and get hurt
then they fell in love that's why
grandpa otto always says
that we are in spain
because
some people put a flag in brussels where
the s
sprawl sprouts come from it's a big
cloth it's all blue with stars
i don't know what it has to do
with the flag the wall
being from germany or brussels or coming
to spain i think that if every one of us
is from a different place that means the
places are not very far from each other
and the people of there are all friends
tomorrow i'll ask mom to take you to
germany after the nap
you